how do you hope the current war in
Israel and Gaza comes to an end uh what
path do you see that can minimize human
suffering in the long term in that part
of the world counterintuitive thing here
I think that the the thing that I think
should be done even though it is very
difficult uh is that um I I would
recommend that Israel engage in the most
cons conspicuous acts of kindness
possible every everything that is the
actual thing that would thwart the goal
ofas this ultimately fights the broader
of hatred in the in the region yes an
eye for an eye makes everyone blind so
really the question is like for for
every Hamas member that you kill how
many did you create mhm and if you
create more than you killed you've not
succeeded